I've voted out I think it's good for the
country because the country wants to
stand on its own until fate we rely on
other countries now we lost to rely on
ourselves
yeah well Scott will Scotland another
thing is if they want to stay in it what
the last to do is the latter showing up
with EU god seals their Euro and then we
can just put a fence right across and
then to get the wrong passports I
thought Scotland was a part of England
but it's quite obvious they don't want
to be do they when you get someone Hayes
I don't know what livings like until
they've actually tried it so all these
MPs wats a divided ad tabbed it they're
probably up normally then we'll a get do
you see what I mean and I'm a company
still struggling now right with many
other companies because survey Europe
bit will you'll need our British
companies back and British people
working against that's what I think
that's my opinion
I mean at end of the day it's up to the
MPs we've got more power than us we are
cats all them what's adult and whether
they listen to what people say it's all
different things